so I wanted to begin my job is basically
to be awake this early in the morning
I'm usually very funny when I haven't
had much sleep and this is always an
exciting week the week of i/o so I
actually wrote my name in the notes just
so I'd remember to say them because
because this is this is usually a time
when we're just running around trying to
get everything ready for tomorrow and
this is always a really fun thing to do
to meet with you guys today and so I'm
really excited that bill asked me to be
here I've been doing this for a really
long time I've been working to make
Android development better delivering
some modestly memorable president's sake
presentations and occasionally maybe
more memorable looks over the years I
particularly like there's John Valjean
look I have on the on the on the you
know left over there so the first thing
I like to do is summarize all the things
that I thought were cool about the day
we had at GDC and so how many people by
a show of hands actually attended and
solve our GDC sessions alright well
that's a but usually about what I
expected that's why I do this because
and I do I group these do kind of help
myself so we talked about a lot of
things about what Google Play is doing
so I put like Google Play hat on we
mentioned that in the last 12 months the
number of Android users who installed a
game more than doubled compared to the
previous year and 40 percent of that
growth is coming from these emerging
markets such as Brazil and India
Indonesia and Mexico we recognized that
because about half of mobile gamers are
women we kicked off an initiative to
celebrate and empower women as players
and creators we did a lot of stuff
inside the store to actually improve the
way that people find games we improved
search on play with personalization such
as the search refinements you see on the
left and recommendations on the right
one things we've done is we've actually
elevated games it's its own destination
in Google Play and that's really
important because it's a foundation for
creating a lot of experiences in the
store that are unique to games such as
more immersive recommendations like
showing trailers or screenshots of
actual gameplay and we also want to give
users a lot more control on how they
explore the catalog
one things that I'm particularly excited
about is that we now have a premium
section on which is highlighting only
paid games and we launched that in q4
and we're refreshing it regularly and
this is also really good because as you
all know we actually have strikethrough
sale pricing now so it's a good way for
for you years to go and find this
content that they really want and we see
a lot of engagement with visitors
scrolling deep into the page looking at
premium content within our
recommendations we're also clearly
highlighting the best the catalog and
one of the major focuses of this year is
actually creating new editorial
experiences including like this rich
long-form content that explains to users
actually what we love about the game so
not only do you see editors choice but
you actually see a couple of things
about why we'd actually did that and
these articles are now live in 17
countries and discovering new games is
really important not just to developers
but to gamers and so similar to the way
we did with premium we actually rolled
out a section they've dedicated to high
quality new games and this is pretty
cool this is a pre-registration feature
and this is this is called milestone
rewards here for pre-registration which
is which it's pretty awesome so this is
a way in which we're incentivizing
people to actually go and pre-register
for games and that is really great it's
also should be at the next a destination
people to find out about the games they
have you know we spend so much time in
live ops trying to drive people back to
content that's that's the way the game
world works now and so we've actually
started to highlight major in-game
events and these live operations through
the way we're doing store featuring and
they're exploring a lot of ways to use
live ops and this hasn't been a pilot
program for several months and we're
seeing promising results and so
hopefully more of you will get to take
part of it we've we've one of the things
we're also piloting is these updates to
the details pages which is pretty cool
so this will actually change depending
on whether or not the user actually has
the game installed so you'll actually
see things that are new and interesting
potentially that are more important you
already have the game installed and you
may have a run in for a while or if you
if you are going to install it and
potentially then you'll see things it'll
actually be more attractive like videos
and stuff like that so once again it's
trying to personalize the store trying
to get people to go and read
engage in content with content through
the Play Store
we also fully redesigned the play games
app which looks really nice and this
allows to let users really launch the
games they've installed and we've added
a number of game reengagement features
and so in addition to tracking
leaderboards and achievements users can
now stielike LiveOps related news and
game YouTube videos and we also have a
new arcade prominently features is this
tag browsing experience to help people
find their favorite game which is pretty
cool and these updates are all leading
to a lot of user engagement and that's
very important as we continue to invest
in the surface this year and we also had
this little thing that maybe have you
have a scene called Google Play Instant
which has is which is really really fun
to play with and I highly recommend
trying it out and when you click try now
you actually get the native application
so you play this with clash it's really
cool it's a great experience and you get
an option to install so you get a whole
bunch of levels but a lot of these games
give you a lot of gameplay and then
really really drive the ability for
people to very very quickly jump into
games and install them right away so
that's those are all kind of the
promotion things we're doing those to
help people discover games also people
reengage in content we're also doing a
lot of things with testing on Play this
is something I'm really excited about we
have internal test tracks so one of the
one of the challenges obviously is you
upload it goes to it goes to a process
before it actually goes live with
internal test track with a hundred users
you can things go live very very quickly
so you can iterate really really rapidly
you don't have to wait for for Google
Play to spend a lot of time staging
things and going through your content
which is great makes it really fast to
use play and I think this is going to
really help people we also have country
targeting on / track now which is which
is awesome so if you haven't if you
haven't used this I'm sure that you'll
love it because this is something people
have been asking us for forever so I'm
really excited about that and this is
something that that's coming soon I
think I'm not sure exactly when it's
coming soon but this actually allows you
to use allows you to create pre-recorded
demo loops and
use them for pre-launch report which is
pretty slick you'll see you'll get
crashing performance metrics including
including frames per second and this
will hopefully allow you to discover
issues even faster and launch with more
confidence I talked a bit about AR core
and what we're doing there it's
currently compatible with a lot of
devices which is great and more are
coming on the way we have a lot of
partners involved with AR core bringing
the power of AR to game developers which
is something that I think is going to be
pretty fun and one of them gets great is
it's actually coming to China so we're
actually working to make our work in
China working actually making sure that
the product is available through these
app stores in China so with why we
Xiaomi and Samsung we also have native
SDKs for popular IDs whether using
Android studio or unity or I'd only
think of those as being IDs but this is
what this lights at I swear we also have
this thing called poly how many people
know about poly this is a product we
have to actually allow people to build
and browse 3d assets and so you can find
all sorts of stuff on there from the
landing landing model of a space shuttle
to apparently a mustache over in the
corner and what's really cool about poly
is that is it it actually allows you to
build these in VR which is which is
pretty slick and we also added an API so
literally you can go to poly and your
app can actually pull assets most of
these assets are Creative Commons
license for free you can just use them
everywhere and it's really a great way
to get started if you're prototyping
games is an awesome thing to have or if
you want to have user-generated content
and you want to have a source for that
this could be pretty fun
so excited about that
we also announced Google Maps gaming
which is that which is a pretty big deal
so we have I have much prettier slides
here hopefully they won't crash which
goes through a little bit of a kind of
things you can do you can actually you
can actually have game in the real world
you can completely customize this game
world with all sorts of Phil parks with
trees turn rivers in the lava flows
you can customize Custer's and teeth and
textures or swap out entire features for
prefabs to create this kind of world
scale environment that's true to the
look and feel of your game so it really
is pretty awesome I've been excited that
we're announcing this we've launched
this I should say and you can also
design game play around real places so
you can drive your you can actually
drive your players to popular places
take them off the beaten path and we
actually help you find great places for
your unique gameplay anywhere in the
world so and of course you can deliver
these at global scale because it's
running on Google's infrastructure so
that should give you a little bit of
peace of mind we've done a lot of stuff
with firebase for game developers to you
know probably as you see you know
firebase includes all of these things
I'm not going to talk about all of them
because I have like five minutes but
this is our mobile development platform
it's a single SDK that combines tons and
tons of stuff and they really they
really work together well so a couple
probably the most they gained a feature
that's most useful other than maybe
crashlytics is Google Analytics for
firebase this is this product has really
really grown a lot recently I don't if
you play with it it has fantastic
real-time support now it it's wonderful
when you're going and debugging to see
those analytics that analytics data
flowing and really quickly and if you're
selling a premium game it's really
important of course to understand or a
freemium game which I understand really
important understand how people are
engaging with your content and as you
can measure all this behavior it no cost
to you we added this predictions API
this is a something we released in beta
last year and this actually allows you
to this build dynamic user groups based
upon predicted behavior which is pretty
slick so you can actually then target
people target these groups using the
firebase cloud messaging and a product
called remote config and out of the box
you'll find you know predictions for
like users who are predicted to soft
turn users were predicted to not turn
spend or not spend all that sort of
thing which is which is which I think is
really important we also as I said a lot
of you to experiment with
these users with remote config so in
this case this is a from mecha hamster
which is one of our samples but you can
see how this works
depending on whether someone is going to
churn or whether someone is is a
dedicated player we can offer them at
different incentives to continue playing
and a new view and you can use this to
change any parameters in your game like
UI ad placement difficulty whatever you
can imagine and out-of-the-box we
actually have this web-based composer
for notifications we also have a REST
API so you can integrate the firebase
cloud messaging into tools that you
maintain and we also have rewarded ad
formats yay so that's that's really
great this is obviously we have rewarded
playable x' which involves you know try
before you buy and we also have multiple
rewarded with multiple options so this
this gives the ability to just to watch
an ad and then choose kind of what
reward the user is going to get and know
this is important we know that the we
know that ads aren't important for
developers to to make sure they're
monetizing a lot of these players that
are very dedicated we also have this
open bidding beta that we're doing which
takes the promise of monetization to the
next level allows people to actually
allows network partners to bid for
inventory simultaneously and in
real-time so that is pretty cool and
then the final thing I wanted to mention
we talked about is it is it we've been
really working on making the Google
cloud work really really fast for people
that are doing things like real-time PvP
and so Dragon Ball legends announced
that they are at that they are using it
for that and I thought that was pretty
cool so I thought I'd end with that from
my component of the slides and we bill
to come up here and tell us a little bit
about what he does with developed with
partner developer relations and what
they do so hopefully this will continue
to work for him so thank you everyone
you
[Applause]